[musique]
c'est premièrement deuxièmement si je
s'opposer inconditionnellement
l'administration d'Etat
[musique]
pour demain était inscrit dans un autre
région et même la série
si en toute sécurité
La société de services publics qui a essayé
enseigner mais elle a réussi parce que je
n'y ont pas souhaité depuis plus de deux mois
et le mien
les animaux devraient découvrir ma propriété
compte tenu de ce qu'ils ont fait, ce n'est pas
illégal ce que j'essaie
et je viens d'essayer
mais reste quand même
de nombreux moyens administratifs
comme ne pas réparer
se déplacer dans le pays
laissé quelque part soit une âme sauvage
le plus gros est beaucoup non plus
au contraire, se perdre dans de grands
ville pour utiliser les fonds
et juste éviter
les gens même où ils peuvent être
directement à la police
en même temps ceux qui
écrire
[musique]
invocations en général